hey guys Pete here today I'm going to
put out a video I've been researching
for a while on the Isle of faces and the
green men and look at all the stuff we
know from the books and then think about
what that might mean for the rest of the
story talked about the ala phases
recently in a couple different videos
including the one on brand and his
purpose and in my tourney at Harrenhal
video part 2 where I talked about Halle
reeds time that he spent here before he
went on to the tournament if you're not
sure what the Isle of faces is it's a
sacred island in the middle of the lake
called the gods eye it's located in the
south eastern Riverlands it's one of the
few known locations of weirwoods in the
south of Westeros with most others
having been cut down and burned on the
map you can see it's sort of in the
middle of everything in that way it's
kind of a rare magical place since the
average Westerosi lives in a world where
magic is pretty much forgot or just the
stuff of myth and legend
there's an old so spake Martin that I
can't really find so I'm going to
paraphrase george RR martin said that we
would learn more about the Isle of faces
and that basically he introduced it too
soon because he thought there was only
going to be three books in the beginning
so its purpose remains a mystery but
let's look at what we've actually
learned through the series so far
maester Luwin from Winterfell tells
brand about the pact and this is really
the first story we hear about it the
pact of course is the agreement between
the first men and the children of the
forest he tells bran that the war
between the two factions had gone on for
a long time but finally that the wise of
both races prevailed the Chiefs and
heroes of the first men met the green
seers and the wood dancers amidst the
weirwood groves of a small island in a
great lake called the gods eye in this
pact the men got most of the land except
for the deep woods and they promised
that they wouldn't cut down any more
weirwood trees maester Luwin tells bran
so the gods might bear witness to the
signing every tree on the island was
given a face and afterward the sacred
order of green men was formed to keep
watch over the Isle of faces so this is
the origin story and one of the things
that's really interesting about it is
it's called the order of the green men
not the order of green
children or something comparable to that
sacred sounds like it means that it's
sacred to both the first men and the
children order makes it sounds like it's
an organization and as mentioned it's
the order of green men not green
children so without any other
information to go on I'm going to assume
that if they were called men on purpose
because they are men beyond Meister Loom
we have two other sources for
information about the Isle of faces
inhabitants the order of the green men
according to old nan the green men
sometimes have antlers she also says
that the green men are the guardians of
the isle that they ride on Elks have
dark green skin and leaves instead of
hair none of what old man says about
them and their appearance is confirmed
by anyone else and actually our third
source of information
maester Yandell tells us in the world of
Ice and Fire that it's probably not true
he tells us that some children may be
living on the Isle with the green men
but he's not sure and really they're not
sure if there's any green men still left
there anyways as mentioned he says that
they're probably not going around with
horns or riding Elks so they're probably
more like real men although that doesn't
really rule out the idea that they might
be some sort of hybrid the most
interesting tidbit from maester Yandell
tells us why people don't really go
there he tells of an occasional account
of some foolhardy young River Lord
taking a boat to the Isle and catching
sight of them before winds rise up or a
flock of Ravens drives them away so we
know that occasionally people try to
visit the Isle of faces but none of them
ever actually make it there in fact
there's only really two people that we
know of that have gone there in recent
times one was Howland Reed which I
mentioned in that video about him and
the other is Adam velaryon who wrote a
dragon there the order of the green man
may still be there or they may not be
and there also may be children of the
forest there or there may not be since
no one ever makes it there we don't
really know and we haven't heard from
Howlin about his time there so we're
going to have to wait until he comes
back into the story to learn more or
we're going to have to wait until brand
takes a trip to the weirwoods
and has a look
what's going on there we won't learn
anything from Adam velarium because he
was killed in battle very shortly after
he supposedly went there so a quick
summary before we get into tinfoil
territory the Isle of faces in the gods
eye is the place where the children and
the first men forged their pact they
carve faces and all the weirwoods and
created the order of the green men to
protect the island from there on out so
if they're green men what is the
difference between that and the two
sides that were involved what we know
about the green men is they were chosen
by both sides they were chosen by the
first men and the children to protect
this Isle if that were the case why
aren't they just a group that consists
of some children and some first men and
why are they called green we hear lots
of green stuff in the story like Green
Dreams green and green seers
so it's kind of like this is a hint as
it's related to that so what are green
seers and what's the difference between
someone who has green dreams and someone
who has actually born a green seer we
have two examples of green seers that we
know as regular characters the
three-eyed crow or Bloodraven and then
bran the older tells the younger just
how rare this actually is he says only
one man in a thousand is born a
skin-changer and only one skin-changer
and a thousand can be a green seer the
children of the forest have eyes as
golden as the Sun but once in a great
while one is born amongst them with eyes
as red as blood or green as the moss on
a tree in the heart of the forest he
says that by these signs do the gods
mark those they have chosen to receive
the gift the chosen ones are not robust
and they're quick years upon the earth
or few for every song must have its
balance but once inside the wood they
linger long indeed a thousand eyes a
hundred skin's wisdom deep as the roots
of ancient trees from that we know that
basically a green seer human like bran
is a million-in-one we can't really be
sure because he says once in a great
while and they don't live very long so
there's not that much that we know about
how
they live because he doesn't tell us
bloodraven also tells bran that his
blood is what makes him a green seer we
know that the Starks have chronic blood
because when they defeated the last
Marsh king they married his daughter to
secure the neck if that's the case is it
too big a bolete to look at the cranek
men as possible descendants of a union
between the first men and the children
of the forest as it turns out there's
mention of this in the world of Ice and
Fire
it says some say they are small in
stature because they intermarried with
the children of the forest beyond that
there's several hints that Jojen tells
us throughout the books that could be
interpreted in that way and stolen the
swords he says we remember the first men
in the neck and the children of the
forest who were friends by saying that
he's basically saying that the cranek
men are not the same as the first men
and also that they're not the same as
the children of the forest but he
implies that they're at that those two
people were actually friends so there
could definitely be a connection that
they had intermarried and what was the
result was what we know now as the
crannogmen we know from mere a story
that the cramming men have their own
magic and while it's not necessarily as
powerful as the children's magic it's
very similar in some of the things that
they do we also know that Jojen who's a
crannogmen has green dreams and that his
father Halland actually talked with the
trees
his father Halland who incidentally is
the only person we know of in recent
times that's actually been to the Isle
of faces
so to avoid rambling on here just think
about that through the Starks marriage
to the cranek bran may have inherited
some of the children of the forces blood
and that's not even what's important
because even if that's not what made him
a green tear he still is a green seer
but I think is important is if you look
back if the quranic' men are the
offspring of a union between the first
men and the children of the forest then
it's pretty likely that the green men
that they're talking about are actually
just the cranek men and maybe they're
the cranek men who are the green seers
of the bunch so is any of this important
for anything that's going on right now I
mean I don't think george RR martin
would have said that we'd learn
more about these you know order of green
men at the Isle of faces if we weren't
going to so it is important in that
sense but I think what's also important
in the immediate future is that one of
the theories that's been around for a
long time is that perhaps Lyanna stark
and rhaegar targaryen were Wed at the
Isle of faces and I think the way the
story's headed we'll probably see that
event through the weirwood trees as bran
goes looking but as I mentioned in my
Helen Reeve IDEO I think he's more
important than just playing a part in
finding out about John's true parentage
so if he has a blood connection to the
children of the forest this could
actually really be important once the
war for the dawn is on I mean like it's
not impossible for brand to communicate
with the children of the forest or
anything like that but Helen could be
that legitimizing connection to get
everyone else to go along with what's
got to happen in order to actually
defeat the White Walkers like I said
it's a bit tinfoil II but it's fun to
think about and like I said I really
don't think that this island is there
for no reason I mean it's right there in
the middle of the map one of the most
important pacts that we know of
throughout time happen there and it's
just sitting there waiting to be
discovered by someone I think at the
very least we're going to see bran go
there through the trees and a vision but
also bran or Helen could possibly
convince someone with a dragon or three
that they need to go there to see
counsel with the men of the order so I
don't know let me know what you guys
think in the comments please like the
video if you found that interesting do
you think that Howland is going to play
a role beyond what we know already and
how do you think the auto phases is
going to be important towards the end of
this story my book giveaway still going
on so you can subscribe now leave a
comment on this video or any of the
other ones where I mention this giveaway
for a chance to win when I hit 28,000
subscribers I'll pick one comment at
random to send that person a copy of the
20th anniversary edition of a game of
Thrones by George RR martin it's the new
illustrated edition and it's super
awesome thanks for watching I'll talk to
you soon